three trillion dollars worth of goods
travels through the Chicago region every
year
much of that is transported on trains
like these making Chicago the busiest
railhub in the US we like to say when
Chicago has a cold the rest of the
nation starts sneezing really because so
much Freight moves through Chicago it
can have a big impact and a stoppage
possibly caused by a nationwide rail
worker strike or bad weather would have
all those trains at a standstill here's
why running railroads are so important
to Chicago in the National economy and
the Ripple effects of a potential
shutdown
in the Chicago region we have a very
multimodal dynamic system we have 10
interstate highways six of the seven
biggest railroad companies have lines in
the Chicago region that system pushes
enormous amounts of freight more than
7.6 million Freight Cargo containers
were moved in Chicago in 2021. that's up
from 6.1 million in 2009. the area is an
important Hub in the intricate
Nationwide Logistics web that gets Goods
all across the country and the Region's
Railways are particularly important
strings in the web in recent years the
city's Rail Yards have been the point of
severe bottlenecks as the supply chain
choked up nationally Chicago sees about
25 percent of all freight trains and 50
percent of all Intermodal trains or the
ones that carry shipping containers or
trailers in the U.S Freight that has to
go from one end of the country to the
other often comes through Chicago
because it has to be switched off to
another railroad that's because six of
the seven major class 1 North American
rail roads converge in Chicago
railroads began growing in the latter
part of the 19th century the East Coast
railroads pushed West the West Coast
railroads pushed East and they met in
Chicago the freight rail industry plays
a huge role in the Region's 645 billion
dollar economy Local transportation and
Logistics firms provided 13.8 billion
dollars in services in 2021. the diverse
economy here really means that a number
of the different types of industries
that we have whether it's manufacturing
whether it's the retail trades the
construction trades the wholesale trades
they're all dependent on Goods being
delivered on a daily basis and over a
quarter of the Region's jobs are in
industries that rely on cargo transport
including rail but it's not just Freight
that would be incapacitated by a rail
stoppage public transit depends on the
railroads too in the Chicago region our
Metro System our Suburban commuter rail
runs on all of the freight Rail lines
those trains the maintenance of the
track is also maintained by the freight
rail workers so if the trains ever
stopped in Chicago it's felt Nationwide
Railroad Strike would have a significant
effect on the local economy a nationwide
rail workers strike averted by Congress
in early December nearly stilled the
Region's bustling Railways there was
worry in the Chicago region about a
possible strike a lot of our jobs a lot
of our businesses are based on that
import export model and they would all
be impacted by a potential strike that
could mean up to 1300 stop trains every
day about 500 of those are freight
trains and 800 are passenger trains
sixty percent of the jobs in the Chicago
region have to be done in person all of
those people if they are traditionally
relying on Transit and Suburban commuter
rails to get into the places they need
to go they just wouldn't be able to and
our roads can't handle 60 percent of
people choosing to drive overtaking
Transit leading up to a possible strike
in September Regional commuter rail
Metro warrant of service disruptions but
that isn't the only thing that could
stop trains bad weather and snow storms
have impacted service in the past in
1999 a blizzard shut down the rail
system affecting operations for months
you had Goods sitting on the railroad
lines like soybeans and corn that were
just going bad and so they weren't even
able to deliver many of the shipments
that were sitting there waiting as a
result the region launched create a plan
to eliminate rail bottlenecks still
another harsh winter struck in 2014.
traffic snarled sending delays
throughout the system trains couldn't
get in here they couldn't get out of
Chicago the whole system kind of seized
up there were trains stacked up kind of
all over the country all over North
America waiting to get somewhere and
they couldn't Goods like cars coal and
fertilizer were all affected by the
stoppages it took warm weather for
traffic to flow efficiently again
that National gridlock made it clear
that railroads including Chicago's are
vital in the supply chain railroads in
Chicago help keep the economy moving it
kind of keeps the rest of the country
moving as well when the rail system has
trouble the rest of that Transportation
infrastructure suffers as well